when I came to your one pound event
whatever I tried learning from other
different areas you were kind of
dropping it everything in the one Pond
course I felt so much value the first
property which I took on rent to rent
was a seven bed second one was 11 bed so
mine was massive property so your cash
flow coming in is good now cash flow I'm
making about three thousand pounds a
month but with so many deals available
that comes gonna make around seven
thousand Pounds wow so I was lucky
enough to convince an agency now you
were skilled you were skilled enough
most of my landlords are from the agency
to whom I stayed with them when I came
to the UK you were a tenant in a HMO I'm
flooded with more deals which I cannot
take one
[Music]
Samuel Johnson Mr I.T engineer from
India came to England for for your job
which you now quit yes that that's true
because you go into property instead
yeah that's the I think property is one
of the things which I wanted to do for a
long time yeah operating ID is one of
the I think it's it's a good thing so a
few years ago when you came to England
did you have any idea that you were
going to end up doing property in
England never never I thought I'll be
just working here saving money sending
to India buy some properties that what I
never thought that I'll be starting some
business in in the UK yeah so you moved
to England was it in around 2017 yeah
2017. and how did you meet me what
happened so I came across you through
your YouTube videos so I actually I
wanted to start something I was like
okay let me start in India it was my
plan I wanted to start there but I kept
on working on here and then I thought
okay why not buy a property in the UK so
the first place was let me buy a
property in UK but when I I started
Googling and finding out like what are
the other ways to do it then you popped
up and said no there's so many other
ways to do it there's so many strategies
available then I was so interested in it
I was like okay let's let's do it and
and yeah that's how I ended up meeting
you and came to the one point course so
you came to the one pound course about
how long ago maybe in June last year
okay June last year so almost a year ago
and then what happened so I came to the
one Bond course and I actually before
coming to the one Pawn course I went to
some of the other events but I went and
joined in training something similar to
this one but I couldn't get the enough
value out of it so but when I came to
your one pound even whatever I tried
learning from other different areas you
were kind of dropping it everything in
the one Pond course I felt so much value
you were adding in and I definitely
joined up to the the advanced program
and said okay let me proceed with it but
when I started knowing more about it
then I'm like all I needed the support
it's like like the inclusivity within
the academy is like that what pushed me
to join the academy and I was like okay
that's what I want to do now so let's
let's join be with the people and you
you and our part of the furniture
everyone knows who you are you're all
the events you're on the masterminds and
the great thing about you Samuel is you
are a big thinker your first property
was well you tell me what was your first
property the first property which I took
on uh rent to rent was a seven bed and
the second one was 11 bed so mine were
massive properties wow yeah seven bad is
your first property yeah and then your
second one is an 11 bed yeah and you've
got two more properties and you've also
you're in the process of securing now to
purchase lease option agreements exactly
yeah so your cash flow coming in is is
good now yeah the cash flow I'm making
about three thousand pounds a month but
I have a target of with so many deals
available that come gonna make around
seven thousand Pounds about seven so at
the moment it's three okay but once
everything comes through and is live and
everything's full we'll be around seven
thousand when did you come to the
decision to quit your job as an I.T
consultant engineer that was a plan for
last year so when I came and joined
learned all about property or came on to
your Mastermind and all the Academy I
was like okay the target what I want to
do is quit my job in six months because
I don't want to do this for rest of my
life so anyway I don't want to do it for
that stuff in my life so why can't I
quit immediately yeah then like if I'm
not going to add value there let me work
on myself and add value for me so that's
what I wanted to do so six months I took
a Target like let me do it within six
months so first deal over the line
Second deal then I got three thousand
pounds cash flow then I said let's quit
the job so you're making three thousand
pounds a month Profit just from your
first two deals exactly yeah wow one and
a half Grand amount eight that's awesome
so the other two then they're not quite
live yet you're no you've totally
secured them contract signed contract
sign and for 18 more bets which is
contract signed
yeah so 18 beds plus the ones that
you've got which is how many beds
currently I'm having 18 bits then
there's 18 more coming up 36. and what
are these are these hmos then yeah these
are existing hmos but both these are
bigger hmos which my patch is an article
4 area so we have quite a lot of hmos in
that area so there are multiple coming
up so what's your service that you're
offering to landlords what is it that
you're offering I'm offering kind of
hands-off experience to the landlord and
also the one which I'm taking on we are
doing light refurbs to the property as
well because these properties the
existing ones which I'm working on are
student properties so they've been as a
student property for so many years but
it's kind of a rundown state where
nobody wants to stay in it or the
landlords are finding it difficult to
renting out see so I was lucky enough to
convince an agency you know you were
skilled you were skilled enough exactly
skilled enough to convince an agency
because all the trainings and all the
mentoring calls which I always keep on
having people were suggesting me what my
script and how to find it out how to go
about it so that what kind of take me to
that line and I'm doing actually in in
those hmos I'm refurbing the hmos
investing some money and then I'm
specifically focusing only on
professionals rather than focusing on
students so my target clients are
specifically from Tech background
clients so I don't have any problems
with my hair tomorrow so yeah that's
that's my main so what you're doing is
you're finding big student houses
exactly where they're a bit run down the
landlord's a lot ugh fed up with them
and then you're coming in how long of a
lease are you signing with these
properties the minimum ones are three
years which is what I'm signing and
there's extendable up to five years as
well yes since I've done it up nicely
the landlords are quite happy with what
I'm doing so they just want to give give
away more properties and sometimes
you're negotiating an option to buy the
property at the end exactly so that's
what we've been doing for both the
properties two of our properties which
we have already placed a lease option on
them because the landlords are already
suffering with it and we are kind of
taking on and managing it so we placed a
lease option to buy them at the seventh
year okay and if they agreed that they
haven't takrit they're working on it as
we said you back you're in negotiation
yeah we are in negotiation in terms of
the price and what value we are giving
to them in seven years but yeah strategy
and where are you doing this uh in
lemington's work sir so how are you
finding these landlords where are they
for me landlords is direct interactions
uh I go to some of the networking events
but most of my landlords are from the
agency one of the letting agency whom I
stayed with them when I came to the UK
so that's how it happened you were a
tenant in ihmo yeah when I came to the
country so I stayed in one of hmos yeah
and when I was going behind so many
agencies trying to convince so many
agencies I just found a reason how I can
get involved with the agency I stepped
inside to the agency and said I'm
looking for hmos and they're like oh are
you looking for rooms I'm like no I'm
looking for HMO I'm like for you yeah I
stayed in one of your properties if you
remember they said yeah yeah we remember
you we have seen you before so like what
do you want to do with that then I said
no I'm I would just want to take on
completely as a as a lease agreement and
then I want to run it as a professional
HMO as all bills inclusive they're like
okay we have worked with companies
before but we have a very bad reputation
with the company so we are not working
on it but I kept going there almost once
in a week and kept being persistent
about it
ah in that way they kind of okay just do
some viewings in couple of properties we
placed offers in couple of properties
then they convinced the landlord for me
that this company will take it and run
it up so you knew that I imagine because
you rented a property but you were just
a hmm and so on you pitched them on
winter event and I said no no that a bad
experience
isn't it awkward coming back the next
week and asking them again when they
already told you not that's fine because
all they want to know is an agent would
want to work with someone as long as
they knew and Trust the person right
it's more about how are you building
trust by just going back again and again
like what are you saying just saying
them that what I'm what I'm trying to do
I think the story behind me coming as a
IIT consultant I'm working in that
particular and I'm focusing on a
different Market I know tenants were
coming from different countries I know
professional tenants already because I
am a professional as well so I just want
to run it up as an all bills inclusive
so for them they didn't focus on
professional Market their target was
student marks sure so for them there's
one less property to worry about yes so
they're like okay so when when I send
yes to you how did you afford to get
through like the referencing and
everything because a big seven bed HMR
that's a big deal luckily they didn't do
any referencing for me oh I didn't do
any references no because they had the
trust because I I was spices then they
know me because I stayed in one of the
hmos so it's like me going back every
day to them I I literally know everyone
from the ages but the thing is that they
normally do like affordability checks
did they not do that they didn't check
on anything because uh they know with
the company which I was working for at
that time so so they know you're in work
and they just said all right fine what
was your salary as an I.T consultant uh
it's 45k okay so you're a decent salary
and your goal was to replace that
through property so when when you got
this first property and you signed for
it were you scared that it wouldn't work
I'm sure I was scared to be honest
because I didn't know what I was doing I
I have all the training I have all the
knowledge I that's what the power of the
mentoring calls I would say I kept on
booking mentoring calls asking them what
I should do how to go about it what
number should I place or how can I find
tenants for me so those were the things
which kept on going to me so you're
being guided yeah on what to say and I
know I'm kind of teasing you about going
back but we were saying that at the time
we were saying be persistent I was
saying to you like turn up again say hey
it's me you know what you got for me
this week that's what you gotta do and
then people that they'll begin to think
man I'll give him some probably just get
him off my back exactly yeah and then
once they're giving you one and it works
did you get the same properties on the
same agent yeah almost all my properties
are from the same agency now
yes so that one yes opened the
floodgates exactly because uh the reason
behind it is they said when they handed
over to me they said we don't want you
to fail so we know it's a risk we are
taking from our side so we hope you do
better but when I did the refurbs I
spent around 2.5
000 pounds which I credit cards wiped it
everything turned up nicely then I sent
the pictures to them with before and
after so they sent it to the directors
and they sent it to the landlords and
everyone was happy and I was able to
fill those rooms within two weeks nice
so then they understood what I was
trying to do and understood the market
and then like Sam can you do the other
one so can you take this one can you
just Place office on this one so why
would the landlords not just spend two
and a half Grand themselves and just
rent it out themselves as a professional
HMR it depends on the landlords because
if it's if the landlord sometimes the
landlords are tired sometimes they are
used to student Market sometimes they
they just don't want to do it they just
don't want the hassle they don't want
the hassle so they've neglected the
property exactly they're busy and you're
coming along and you're saying I want
your crumbs you're not bothered about
putting some elbow grease and redoing it
up and remarketing it you don't want to
do all that you don't want the hassle
let me do it I'll give you a guaranteed
rent how much rent are you paying that
landlord uh the seven bed I'm paying 2
200. the lane agent are presumably
getting their commit their commission so
they're happy the landlord's getting his
rent he's happy and then you're renting
it out how much do you rent it for I'm
renting it out for five seven five and
six hundred each room so you're renting
it for about four thousand and then you
who's paying the bills I'm taking care
of the bills and how much are they so
the the gas and electricity is around
700 pounds the council taxes are about
100 pounds and the the other charges
cleaning and everything is at 100 so a
thousand pounds all in so you're making
about a thousand pounds profit and then
how much rent are you paying for this
for the second one the second one for
the 11 bed I'm paying 2
just two grand yeah and there's 11
bedrooms yeah exactly so that one's even
more profitable yeah that's making me
around 2 200 profit
damn how much did you have to spend on
it I spent around 6 000 pounds on that
one because it was in a very run down
state but I'm making two thousand pound
profit on it yeah how's life changed
then like when you saw the money coming
in what did you think were you shocked I
was working at that time when when I
kind of consistently did all these
properties and when I see the money
coming inside every month I'm like I
don't want to do my job anymore because
I can make that particular money when
I'm without doing anything so I decided
to quit the job and said I can make
still more because I had a consistent
Pipeline and I can make more so why not
why not spend my time efficiently in
your business yeah exactly and then when
you quit your job I was expecting you to
go really hard on the property thing but
you didn't you just book it off to India
we didn't see you for like at least a
month what happened you know actually
when I resigned my job I would like like
let me go back to India uh for a month
to set right the things whichever is
happening there and then I came back I
kind of had a break and bear the holiday
yeah was the money still coming in from
the properties yeah money was still
coming in I was making profit I think I
I just had two calls when I was in India
from my tenants saying that one of the
switchboards broken or something I just
sent to my electrician to fix it and it
was completely passive and I was like
yeah it's really working wow so not only
are you making 3000 miles a month but
it's pretty passive yeah pretty passive
I kind of work uh one hour on both the
properties just visit them do the
numbers and yeah and your next two
properties that are going to be going
through next month they're going to be
making a similar sort of profit all that
yeah exactly so we have signed up an
eight bed uh we have signed up a 10 by
10 on Suites and also we are currently
working on a six bed and a seven bed as
well so it's like in four
do you miss your job no no no not at all
because I I think I'm more happier now
working for myself yeah even though I'm
putting in more efforts I'm getting to
meet people it in a more strategic way
in terms of have a focus on what I want
to be achieved where I want to go even
if I work for a job it's going to still
give me five percent or ten percent
every year but working for myself I can
make 300 percent of 400 percent more
grow the business it it's kind of an
asset for the family and for anybody
whoever is coming in what do you family
think and your wife about how how are
you doing in property they're pretty
happy in terms of it not all my family
members know about it yet it's just my
mom my brother and my first Circle know
about it I haven't opened up anyone to
anyone because they're all back in India
so I don't want them to worry about it
in terms of what is he trying to do and
stuff so I'm keeping it close now I
thought I'll help them all around in
terms of once I go back and try to do
that what's the long-time plan then are
you going to start using the money and
then buying houses yeah so the long-term
goal is to get into brrs to hm yeah
because you could buy run-down hmos
student ones that are really tacky and
you can buy them and then you could do
them up and then get a commercial
valuation refinance them and grow your
actual portfolio as well as controlling
properties exactly so that's the plan
now so I've since I know the agent since
I know a couple of landlords I'm I'm
kind of flooded with more deals now
really yeah I'm flooded with more deals
which I cannot take on so damn pretty
much in talks with some of the investors
to kind of joint venture and deal source
so finances for you are good now yeah
that's awesome been working with me over
the last sort of six months that's been
it completely changed my life to be
honest that's what I would say because
whenever I meet I crew some of the
events and whenever I meet some people
they have that doubts in them like
whether can they achieve it so I said
take me as an example who came into this
country five years before no contacts
nothing so being in the academy being
around the circle it's like academies
like a second family to me now like
everybody I speak to everyone once in a
week and I meet so many people help
around everyone just pulling each other
up so yeah I would say it's it's
life-changing boy you've done extremely
well what will be your best piece of
advice for somebody wanting to get
started and and do what you've done best
advice would be to be persistent learn
what you want to know it's like the
knowledge the network and being
persistent in taking actions so that
would be the and you mentioned about the
one pound course that he went to what
was what was that like one pound course
is really amazing because when when I
came into that course that's where I saw
the inclusivity of everyone the the
people around there everybody trying to
help you trying to help you to get to
that level yeah so that's the reason
immediately I said I needed the support
I needed the people I needed the
knowledge so it's best to be in the
circle get inside the circle then all
this left up to you is push yourself to
the Limit and then take action so if you
take actions and B in the circle then
obviously you're gonna win boy you did
so well man big respect to what you've
achieved Samuel so if you want to come
down to the one pound property investors
crash course like a man Samuel did
you're gonna have your mind blown when
you see what's possible in this market
this year and what you can achieve is
incredible so I'm going to leave a link
in the description get booked on it's
literally one pound no catches come and
spend the day with me and the team I'll
see you there enjoy
thank you
[Music]